[Music]
Chicharito vegetarian Torito
[Applause]
[Applause]
I actually had a very different video
planned for this week but at the same
time I also wanted to uphold a promise
that I made a while back in my video
about dungeon traversal I asked you guys
to submit some of your ideas regarding
which items you want to see returned or
newly introduced in breadth - Wow -
since I recently hit the glorious 1,000
subscriber milestone I wanted to do
something in return so in this video
I'll be going over some of the ideas
that you submitted now this isn't a top
ten or anything like that the order
doesn't dictate which ideas I like the
most if your idea didn't make it in
don't stress it I will do more viewer
suggestions in the future being able to
communicate with you all and listening
to your feedback and suggestions is
something I enjoy greatly it's what
YouTube is about for me it's not just
visual entertainment it's also a
community at the end of the video I will
also give an update about the channel
and what to expect for me in the near
future but enough of my rambling let's
get started the first suggestion is from
Bret black now when I first read this I
thought wait word a crab claw that's
kind of silly but the more I kept
thinking about it the more amazing the
idea started to become if we are to
assume that Link's green hand will be
able to morph into all kinds of
different shapes and grant him different
abilities a giant claw is actually quite
feasible of course it doesn't have to be
specifically a crab claw could just be a
big hand or Talent
it kind of reminds me of Midna x' hand
from Twilight Princess which she also
uses to grab or deflect giant objects
and is even strong enough to flip beast
Ganon on his side now the Chaika slate
was an amazing item in breath the wild
probably the best item ever to be
introduced when it comes to versatility
however the mag nieces rune although
very cool I thought was fine for puzzle
solving but in terms of combat
implications it was a bit on the slow
side imagine being able to pick up
boulders or other giant objects and
being able to hurl them towards your
enemies or during a boss fight like the
one we saw with master Koga having to
catch giant spike balls launched in your
direction from the air and throwing them
back and as Brett states this would also
double as a progression item essentially
replacing the power brace
LED Titans mid or silver and golden
gauntlets this one's from Seth Falconer
now you suggested a lot of different
ideas but I had to go with the Hylian
guitarman not just because it's awesome
but if we look at some of the early
concept art from brough dewild we can
see that this was in fact something the
zelda team was considering not only that
but we can also see that a motorcycle
was also something that didn't make it
into the base game but eventually did
make it into the DLC since the sequel to
breath the wild was initially supposed
to be DLC 3 the guitar might just have a
chance not a harp or a flute or any of
these weak-ass instruments get out of
here it's about high time link actually
started shredding
[Music]
[Music]
actually this wouldn't even be a first
for link as in majora's mask he also
plays guitar or fishbone wait how does
that even work
this suggestion ties in with two other
comments I got from Peter ganderton and
Gabriel the obsessive who both expressed
a similar desire for the return of
instruments and I agree instruments have
always been something that sets the
series apart and also influences the
music score greatly now I know what
you're thinking if this will indeed be
an electric guitar like the one we see
in the concept art how will it produce
sound without an amplifier one word
magic this was a popular one requested
by knox nintendo 7 and hidden color by
the way sorry if i butcher and of your
names
I think the whip would definitely work
well with breath the wilds engine it's a
tool that is quite versatile since it
can be used for both means of traversal
a way to pull levers from afar and
functions as a weapon or if the wall
didn't make use of any mechanics that
involve having to swing around like we
saw in the Wind Waker Twilight Princess
and Skyward Sword link now has a type of
mobility never before seen in the series
yet there were no additional items to
boost his mobility even further the
closest we came to an upgrade in terms
of mobility was Ravalli scale which was
slow in terms of startup and had limited
use I also want to give an honorable
mention to drew it writer who suggested
the return of the grappling hook from
the Wind Waker which functions very
similar however the whip has a slight
edge over the grappling hook in my
opinion it's faster to use both in terms
of traversal and combat the only thing
the grappling hook has over the whip is
the ability to climb up but if you ask
me that only gives it more reason to
coexist with the modern take on the hook
shot or claw shot which also grants the
player the option to reel themselves in
in the Wind Waker the grappling hook and
hook shot didn't get in each other's way
because one they were introduced very
far apart one in the very first dungeon
and the other in the last one
not counting Ganon's Tower and two both
had clear limitations that made sure
that one would not nullify the other I
think there's a reason why there was no
grappling hook in Twilight Princess
since the clash
had much more options this time around
thus for Skyward Sword which also had to
double claw shot they chose to implement
the whip instead of the grappling hook
being able to disarm enemies from a
distance grab onto designated targets
and swing across gaps or even run along
walls sounds like an absolute blast and
at the same time it wouldn't get in the
way of the hook shot as both have their
limitations next we have sword dashing
suggested by fire hawk all I can say
about this one is yes please we've seen
sword dashing plenty of times in the 2d
games but was never used for the 3d
installments in general it was a bit of
a shame that in breath the wild being
able to run faster was limited to only
nighttime and with specific outfits
equipped sword dashing could work very
well with breath the wilds huge open
world and yet again both for traversing
the landscape as well as using it for
combat introducing the Pegasus boots or
something similar would be a welcome
inclusion and just like in the 2d games
it could even be combined with Lynx
jumping ability and paraglider to scale
greater distances horizontally that's
all I have to say about that one this
one was submitted by Elijah's - and I
gotta say man I'm digging this idea now
I wouldn't say controlling a statue is
very exciting in the past they were
quite slow and clunky to use in combat I
think this idea could be fleshed out
further of course being able to
temporarily possess a non organic object
and have it fight for you is very
appealing and you know what there is
actually something that we could use for
this purpose Hyrule is absolutely
littered with the cave Guardians imagine
being able to take control of one after
all the fear and frustration they put us
through in the first game it would be
nice to have one on our side this time
around depending on if they still have
enough of their legs intact they could
even be able to move we've seen that
even though they are autonomous they are
not immune to being corrupted or taken
over it is time to turn the tide on
Ganondorf and give him a taste of his
own medicine
sir nicholas & Lomb oliver j showed an
interest in a return of the beetle and
well good news this was also found in
the concept art so this one also
definitely has a chance to make it in
especially if Nintendo is planning to
implement unused ideas which in all
probability they will I can definitely
see why people want the beetle to return
as it's a very unique item and one of
the more recent brand-new Zelda items to
be introduced to the series if
implemented in breadth the while - I
wouldn't change much to its
functionality except for the way you
control it I can definitely see the
beetle working great with the gyro amy
using slight tilts of the switch or pro
controller to change direction at the
same time having the option to use the
analog stick as an alternative would be
nice - not everyone enjoys having to
tilt their controller or switch at
awkward angles luckily Nintendo seems to
have learned from its past mistakes and
already gave this option in both breath
the wild and Mario Odyssey breath the
wild rewarded creativity by playing
around with the physics and trying out
all kinds of different things the beetle
would definitely supplement this for
some next-level strategies being able to
pick up small rocks explosive barrels or
other items and bombard enemy camps fly
straight into enemies like a kamikaze
pilot and if the chicest leg were to
make a return or at the very least
remote bombs dropping a bomb picking it
up with the beetle and turning it into a
b-17 bomber the sky is the limit
another honorable mention goes to Andrew
Chapman who suggested something similar
but rather than the actual beetle it
would be a boomerang that behaves
similarly
this one's from werewolf 9 1/4 instead
of just using a glorified vacuum cleaner
he presents the idea of pointing it onto
the ground and blasting a gust of air to
launch yourself upwards a bit like
Rivoli's gale but faster and with less
height as not to make it to Opie so
basically we are rocket jumping like in
quake but without blowing your legs to
pieces and hurting yourself with each
jump I never found the gust gr to be a
particularly interesting item especially
in Skyward Sword
but if used in this manner I can imagine
this being tons of fun to use especially
when combined with the
glider Paulie Griffin also came up with
a lot of ideas so I again had to choose
one a portable Guardian laser like the
one the blight cannons are carrying the
most likely way I would see this being
implemented is if Lynx hand is able to
transform into different types of
devices again like in the concept art
and I am all for it let's go full
Megaman let's give Samus a run for our
money and give link a freaking arm
cannon tech mean why not write an
alternative to this being one of Link's
hand morphing abilities would be if it
simply functions as a regular weapon
with limited durability similar to the
different elemental rods found in breath
the wild perhaps this could even be an
item that can be crafted by none other
than Robbie I mean he is the expert at
ancient weapon technology after all
maybe if given the right parts he could
extract the firing mechanism from a
guardian and turn it into a cannon
capable of being wielded by a human well
get on it old man the last one comes
from evil tada 9 a wolf transformation
to jump further track smell or to run
faster I'm a bit conflicted about this
one since when it comes to the main
gimmick of a game they never repeat it
twice in the exact same manner we did
have the option to put wolf link in
breath the wild through the use of
amiibos but this worked very differently
I personally don't think they would
allow link to transform into a wolf
himself as that has already been done
before Nintendo usually strives for
something new however there is an
alternative in creating a champion it
reads that wolf link was actually a
toned down version of an idea they had
in mind during the early stages of
development this creature would have
been able to receive commands navigate
fight alongside you follow you around
and even talk perhaps we could see a
more fleshed-out version of this
returning in the sequel where you can
give actual commands like in fallout 4
or even take control of your companion
temporarily and as you stated in your
idea track sense jump gaps or crawl
through small spaces that link cannot
reverse it switches for you etc and that
is a wrap
or this one all of these ideas at the
same time would probably be too much for
the zelda team to handle but we can hope
that at least some of these ideas make
it into the new game I want to have some
closing words before I end this video
first off a big thank you to everyone
who supported me so far I only started
uploading content a little over a month
ago and the warm welcome I've received
is more than I could have ever wished
for to all of you who subscribed
commented on my videos giving me
feedback and ideas or corrected mistakes
and oversights it's very much
appreciated I had a lot of fun making
this video and going through all of your
ideas we can do something similar for
the next milestone or maybe by that time
there's something else you would like me
to cover as for the near future since I
surpassed the 1k subscribers I will soon
be able to make community posts right
here on YouTube I think it takes about a
week for it to activate so from that
point on I will be able to give you guys
two direct updates on projects that I'm
working on I'm not exactly a social
media person but I am considering
setting up a Twitter account as well as
an alternative way to communicate with
you all so when I get around to it I
will let you know about it in terms of
upcoming projects I have a couple of
different things on the way since you
guys seem to really appreciate my take
on Zelda lore I will be doing those more
often however I will not stop doing game
analysis and mechanics either as a
matter of fact I have two different
videos about game mechanics planned both
of which will be collaborations for one
of them I will once again be modeling a
dungeon idea in blender so I hope you
look forward to that these videos will
drop around mid to late June at the
earliest as I'm of course dependent on
other people's schedules as for the
upcoming weeks I have two different
videos planned I want to do another lore
video and I also want to do a more
personal video about my experience with
breath the wild and why I think the game
is such an important milestone now for
my question to you guys and gals is
which video would you prefer to see for
next week lore or a more personal tale
be sure to let me know down in the
comments one quick final notice I've had
a couple of people requesting me to post
my edit of the breath the wild 2 trailer
as a separate video and the answer to
that is yes I'm going to do some little
touch-ups on the sound of the trailer
and maybe even pay a professional to mix
and master
so it can be the best it can possibly be
if and when my channel gets monetized I
will make sure that this video will not
have any ads on it
so you can always watch it without
interruption I will also provide a
download link to the original mp4 in
case anyone wants to use it for whatever
personal purpose if you want to stay up
to date on my latest uploads consider
subscribing hitting the Bell you know
how it goes thank you all for watching
and I will see you in the next video
this is Don signing off and have a good
one